well hello everyone welcome to Friday's
with me and John Luke I'm Joey
and today we are going to be playing a
wonderful game that you may remember
from 2006 yeah 11 years ago it's called
sneak King it was originally a Burger
King uh packing game or you could buy it
at Burger King for like three five bucks
I think those five bucks so Ben was
telling me it's three bucks but now it
goes for five bucks so it actually is
increased in value actually right
specifically with the the Burger King if
you guys remember that um there was the
mascot yeah I think he's still by the
way I've never played this game before
I've seen bits and pieces of it online
it was actually my first time
experiencing this [ __ ] is well made
this is good pocket bike racer like a
bike racer for three dollars this is
already worth so yeah I think you should
probably start this or else is probably
gonna loop does it Lou oh it does it I
don't know nope there you go press Start
director mango critic this is a
streamline it this is the stream my life
has been needing awesomes in all of us
too so yeah thank you guys for joining
us we will be streaming again on
gamespot.com and on youtube on twitch
every day every weekday me and John Luke
have Friday here every Friday and if you
stay tuned we also have a couple of
things to give away if you can see it
behind us there's a few Lego dimensions
things that'll be our uh USA the our
kids meal prizes for everyone there's a
lot of achievements right now yeah
whoever is account this
doesn't have any Lucas Rob's you Yuki
and the YouTube chat she says or he says
uh play big bumpin I don't really I
could not find my copy of big bump in
that home oh I forgot Ben he said he
maybe had a copy and he might have
brought it in I gotta ask him shoot Ben
if you're watching thanks for watching
and you did bring it over come on come
on down okay I got it I gotta be on
point here so sneak king is basically
the the Metal Gear Solid slash
Assassin's Creed ripoff of some sort a
year a year before assassin's creed came
out oh that's right yeah ahead of its
time so basically you're
yeah so that better a little bit better
yeah let us know if the volume mix needs
to be Justin all right well already the
controls are pretty terrible yeah all
right Sarah they're inverted camera it's
inverted camera comes first so let's you
have no Jersey no choice okay cool start
so yeah so your missions will come from
those little newspapers and I got each
mission complete you going feeding into
the pose Oh what do I do
No okay get in the circle hey what book
and so you can hide in the objects so
like if there's a dumpster or gameplay
might be slightly higher but not much
something volume is too low okay I'm in
here now okay so there's nobody people
have their own little Casa they can take
put right easiest way for right now is
to just go up right behind someone I
believe it's X or Y okay yeah wasn't a a
why since be trans lumberjack here
suggests without getting your head
chopped off now it's fine okay I think
he's busy
the right NPC this camera is really bad
it's like it's it's got a swing to it so
even the way it keeps moving he wants
that guy everything he's he wants a
burger oh yeah
so as long as you could get pretty close
oh yeah whoa all right the cone of
vision Kenneth get me Oh regular
surprise everyone stop it maximum he is
now satisfied gameplay is too high
you're too low okay bracelet raise outs
Joey let me know how that's somebody
says from all the great games you could
be streaming you chose this yeah welcome
to a jo hangjo click friday livestream
this is what we do now this is what we
do I guess that's our thing yeah until
next week so next week we're actually
gonna be streaming splatoon - pizzette
game comes out on Friday we're gonna
stream a real current video game
kummerow tattoo it says Saul sleek looks
different he sure does got a nice crown
which is I'd say caution logging ahead
okay so you need three deliveries here
so just find anyone with it alright
am i hiding oh you could knock someone
out with that okay
all these guys can go home cuz I can
just do all this myself see that person
probably burger right now no nothing no
yeah I can't do anything with them try
going up here there's a dangerously
large blades I can't
[Music]
boy this camera can't believe it's
inverted and I can't adjust it that's a
guy there we go oh boy well there's a
hunk you guys I know I see Oh are they
very hungry when they pass down what do
I do
is it too late don't just creep over
them go away help I better go that guy
are they dead now
no they're just resting do they do they
get back up yeah oh okay so that's
usually what happens when you get really
hungry you just pass out right yeah but
then you just wake up in Spanish first
one all right the arkham knight hero
says burger q related game yes you are
correct it is part of the 2006 series of
licensed Burger King game for that as
you can see this game was a huge
influence on the predator stealth
missions from the art of night series
they were very heavy rock rock said
mister devil whose governments buy it
[Music]
also fun fact about these games ah now
they are backwards compatible with the
original Xbox despite being released in
2006 so wait I can plug this I can put
this into an Xbox like an original Xbox
can what's weird
although I don't think it's backwards
compatible on a group on an Xbox one we
are playing on an original piece I mean
I don't think Microsoft put it in there
it would definitely advertise that that
was the case no man there's someone ok
maybe I go back to the original area
this way more people there I guess so
I'm gonna try to chop this though if I
can no boobs asking if GameSpot reviewed
it back in the day that's a good
question
you won't look that up so you gave it
for any of those games I would love to
know
oh that guy like I need some I got him I
got him I got him
all sigh I figured out if I hold trigger
I run but that I got new mission Wow
guess what guess what we guess what
GameSpot gave the game six I'm gonna say
four was a 5.8 5.8 that's how we came
yeah that's back when we would do that
I got a C rank all right let's keep
going all right so pick a new that was
cleared okay that's the like how all the
all the text is Old English sandwich a
true sneak King would never keep the
buttery goodness of this crew sandwich
register trademark sandwiches why don't
you at you don't need to add sandwiches
after cuz sandwich it already has the
name sandwich in it it's Chris on Chris
on which her sandwich will cos it's a
sandwich with croissants
[Music]
there's guys one there's one there's a
lady friend so maybe try heightening one
of those things okay I'm just gonna wait
I feel like it's too much effort - yeah
just go hide in these things oh shoot no
I screwed up it's fine you still get the
delivery fortunately this is game of the
year stream yes we're streaming our game
of the years every year sneaking no gold
but I got caught by the person who just
caught me all right like that doesn't
make anything just a that makes no sense
she should be fine it'll deliver oh so
you Wow okay someone hit you they really
have to be sneaking sneaking early
stealth games were really punishing huh
I mean it was either this or else was
around Oh sounds fun it's our history
second one yeah those games were those
old ones are pretty punishing I'm
pulling you out
sneaking flares do
that little did a little curtsy all
right so very very nice person over here
yeah she still has the cone there some
you hide hiding that
I think the only thing that hiding and
popping out gives you is like I guess a
bigger flourish oh oh you can pop out
and deliver yeah oh okay well I want to
try and do that but like right now it's
a lumberjack right there yeah it just
seems like it's way easier to do it this
way
oh look at that maximum we're gonna
dance he's just like what are you doing
just oh there please okay thank you just
better chopping wood well thank you for
that sandwich see next target I guess I
said yet the like you have to hide hi
pop Alfred I assume no my score would be
based on a combination of like time
though like you did it in like a really
quick amount of time I don't think it
matters
[Music]
20 missions I hope that spread out
throughout the whole game and not just
in this one area oh boy
someone's asking about Kingdom Hearts
2.8 what price should you pick it up at
oh no they had on prime deal as a
pricing or at one point for like seven
bucks
one delivery person that looks like I
gave him a some nuggets the guy already
laughs you don't need that you don't
stop bowing he's uh no one's there I
didn't in just asking okay I didn't in
just asking how much does his crap worth
well it used to be worth three dollars
and out till 5:00 so the valium is only
increased the value has increased by 60%
yep Wow perform three flourishes if you
go make sure you get that that meter up
okay
to grin thief says he would pay no more
than two bucks fine for cheaper nowadays
[Music]
two guys over there this really
represents is like bygone era of just
bizarre videogame marketing remember
things like Pepsi man yes the 7up doc
yep that they turned into a character
you know even like chester Cheetah for
the Cheetos right and that's gonna had
had a game at one point this definitely
may be like the latest example because a
lot of those were very early like
PlayStation want Super Nintendo oh
there's a lot of people over here though
oh no they're all dropping like flies
go get the Lumberjacks oh that guy no
4mins watching me form and move I need
to deliver these people they're tasty
sacks
[Music]
where's three good we're not talking
smack about pools but smack we're just
saying over those yeah one of the many
examples the history so speak of the UH
at one point said I'm watching game her
profile picture that was a thing of the
360 era that I really loved was gamer
profiles yeah where there's a lot of
marketing stuff behind them so you'd
have like a Best Buy logo as your gamer
profile so me my friends would all just
like try and have the stupidest like
free gamer profile because they're all
free right yeah
my the one I finally ended on was a
picture of molder from the x-files just
pretty good these guys they're hungry
they're working hard there's so much
variety to this gameplay I mean I think
the variety will come in the
environments since I know there are four
four worlds so to speak I think there
was annoyed of video game as well
yeah no ID was up at Pizza Hut or no no
Domino's right was annoyed annoyed yeah
I know I D yeah the idea was like he
really annoys you and loves pizza or
something yeah the noise oh yeah I know
it's like stir big mascot I really don't
okay stream out chat I don't know if you
have ever seen it's the weirdest idea
for a mascot yeah there's the game right
there it's called yo noise Wow
alright well oh man double like I just
watch by it I was like alright let's do
it
this keeps going crushing it keep the
food han Gisele thin air Luther King
we're still going
Iceman works uh this is a sneak King
when a 2006 is greatest hits great as a
fast food related
look at that look at that
new missions
I really want to get to the
the suburban like cul-de-sac area
because I feel that got a thief I gotta
be awesome be furburger because that is
where I feel that game everything I mean
I've seen if the game isn't the coldest
accurate yeah because something about
the idea of like hiding in a trash can
in someone's uh like yard why a
lumberyard of all places I wondered yeah
that's a bit weird because started out
like in a mall which would get to all
these other areas I'm very much yeah
I delivered doubled the jolts by not
only surprising some lucky sama working
with a stimulating cup of BK Joe coffee
but doing it from within a hiding place
okay so we need doing a hiding place
yeah well the way that persons walking
we may begin one of these barrels I
would say here go ahead or go ahead of
her and get in toward those trucks okay
she'sshe's gonna paint soon I know but
like there's no way I could time that
[Music]
yep okay alternate one didn't just says
these graphics though you know what this
is not the worst looking game from 2006
like no just really this really isn't
like where do you think this person's
going maybe this truck yeah yes yeah
please don't you got yeah I think so I
hopped out you got it nice the cup that
wasn't as cool he just kind of slowly
like right yeah coffee instead he's just
like pulling oh yeah here you go
well I did it right we got 14 stand
directly outside their cone in front of
that I believe so
I think he just redid the first mission
did I get out of here I would shoot
[Music]
yeah behind that truck no bunch of a
bunch of them a dream fairy night see
you by the way we are we are giving away
a bunch of Lego dimensions for years to
three lucky winners in all three of our
chats which at some point Joe II will
once you actually joint well it's been
about 20 minutes one at lunch anyone
should give out the first one alright
okay so I guess what are these
stipulations for we're giving these away
they didn't really it didn't really come
up with one for this one much less a
plan than our past our previous dream
let's agree with question seems like yes
I can kind of just stand in front of
them make three successful delivery a
half okay I got 52 seconds and going
Simpsons burger good this is Burger King
trivia oh man do you want to quickly
come with some Burger King trivia no I'm
so sorry you're dead I'm knocking we'll
just creep up and then press the button
perfect I'm definitely not gonna make it
I have oh I can get this guy maybe if he
moves around he's looking straight at
you but his cone of vision I'll kill it
only goes about preaching from I was
able to get to about five seconds
while Lego dimensions can you get away
this one well we only have one copy to
sneak King and we're not gonna we don't
have 34 okay you can't give that up
unfortunately preserved all right good
game you try it I'll keep doing this Joe
if you want to yeah let me let me let me
think
I mean a hot second all right I'm sorry
to put you on the spot
hello there's a person up there oh
really
yeah why they actually make you
coordinate yeah really slow he's asking
if there was a Burger King kart racer
yes and you have it oh they got all into
all the way oh this is bad I'm gonna
restart this one this is not working out
restart challenge okay first rat do not
go after well maybe I can if I
immediately go up who's asking
or keep saying super simple for the
giveaway just guess what number I'm
thinking of I think that's better okay
here how about for the YouTube chat if
you would like to win one of these are
Lego dimensions I want you to guess me
what barbecue
I'm thinking of right now Wow
if none of you come close I'll pick the
closest one
nope get down from there and really lose
a lot it was a mistake to go up to the
water tower
I agree we're gonna a lot of response
from the twitch tab and I YouTube okay
whoever whoever gets it first or close
what I got
nope there's person come on models mine
guys getting up
need one more right yep I'm very happy
via the clock stops here in this me to
lumberjack yeah I got it Oh dizzy the
king he says chicken fries and that is
correct
oh no regular sir from I uh I screwed up
I was not paying attention well I can
get this guy though and get this guy and
did this guy yes
we have a winner our first winner so
dizzy the king if you can I think our
giveaway person Shiva or social media
expert so honored they can pick four of
these Lego dimension prizes oh cool the
way so why don't you explain to them
what their options are all right if you
are listening baiji let's see what we
got see turn the mic here so if you'd
like to pick one how many oh well
there's 12 and they can pick four they
can pick four so we have a grimley's one
we have Sonic the Hedgehog we're going
for et there's one for Ghostbusters
Adventure Time Harry Potter
fantastic beasts and where to find them
couple Harry Potter is a couple of Harry
Potter's I see a mr. t I believe in the
back that might be what the the a-team
there's a mission impossible thing oh
yeah mission impossible as well and then
one more small one I can't make it I
don't know what I think it's like a
mystery box small mystery box thing go
get this guy
[Music]
get really get these portions
it's a vision if you want to pick from
anyone any three of those well
we'll hook you up any for a penny for
its art for oh come on I just gave you
the food hi hi hi hi night oh you're
good I got I got Oh No well now she
doesn't want a burger anymore I know
it's just like I saw you so I don't want
you okay you got 30 seconds can you put
down the bridge I'm hoping all the clock
isn't stopping here no
oh no that person's gonna pass out
before and get to them oh this person
okay yeah I think you're good to get
around good he's like no you're not do
we okay
yes yes yes yes
Bob Genesis showed them on camera it's
good point Joey maybe maybe I bring him
over yeah bring him over but he picked
the sonic et Ghostbusters and Harry
Potter so let me I'll be right back
perfect continue
[Music]
I'm just gonna give you mine sneaking
this game has not much variety a variety
now very repetitive game Congrats to
digi here's the Harry Potter one right
here I know it's hard to see but Sonic 4
and get full screen for a second you
want to show that man doesn't matter
well I'm just playing sneaking over here
I'm gonna do her 7 hash browns and
that's gonna be 10 passion
you got the sonic one right here has a
Harry Potter also easy
last one this is big one there's a
Ghostbusters one right there
note that steam new Ghostbusters and not
the old ones and in case you were
wondering
congratulations I will put those aside
for you okay
Hey Dude oh wait do you want get back to
the game
oh yeah do come on you got you got your
food I got deliver these we got two guys
over there make sure they don't think
that was on your tail Oh guys guys leave
me alone I thought this was gonna be a
walk in the park for a walk a walk in
the lumber yard
[Music]
because you were running it I know but
like I would don't run house or get
there in time I got seven rounds
let's try restarting this one so instant
Baconator Baconator is not for wrong
wrong brand is there a Wendy's video
game that's good all right I don't think
so someone said there was a McDonald's
one I'm trying to remember I would play
a a Wendy's visual novel starring that
that soondae anime Wendy that everyone
keeps drawing all about Ida so I said my
last name was prepared by any chance no
but at one point my parents did I don't
have a middle name but my parents did at
one point entertain the idea of making
it my middle name it was a very brief
brief thought though I think it got
passed like a minute before they were
like now that's already pushing it right
yeah exactly
all right oh that one's hunger pains fun
yes
I'd save you
mr. mean says how old is this game 11
years 11 years oh damn people are hungry
here what feet lift and rise walk right
over him
[Music]
yeah I feel like I've just like I'm not
even trying just like getting that
rhythm down Oh
I'm curious how do I get the stuff so
Shiva is gonna contact you sent you a
message over on YouTube and you'll get
your information and then she'll send it
you Sam look out for that as we son says
do another giveaway we will but
unfortunately we're all doing it for
each of our chat so if you're on YouTube
you've already lost a chance but if you
want to head over to the twitch chats
try and win a one fair you can you can
try that pretty boys
recon x89 is asking you to do your best
Patrick Stewart voice I don't think I
really have one what does it sound like
well he's British
I feel like in gay engaged not know
that's terrible
buzz awful that's a bad Patrick Stewart
I do not have the ability he did - not
very many people do now let's continue
here I'm no said uh the store is locked
oh yeah that's probably Oh move to
sawmill well that's where you are yeah
yeah wow there's a lot of areas how do I
have to do how many missions to add
maybe maybe unlock up there - I hope so
I'm hoping yeah there's like that whole
area the whole second area the sawmill
the Anthony's like he's pretty pretty
upset about the Baconator coming
because you guys you guys know you're
fast - they're gonna be the sneaky or
miss omelette sandwiches
[Music]
the problem is it takes so long to do
the animations ideally it's easier
so where'd you give it away now
omelette omelette sandwiches I'm an
in-game not not here do phone to buses
do a wrong voice hey this is a guy I'm
on the Gulf this is that yeah my food
donate to my charity I remember that
famous Ronald McDonald commercial we
need we need a game starting the
Hamburglar in the style of payday this
is a there clearly is a Hamburg there is
a McDonald's video game where you can be
the Hamburglar or the hamburger lose in
it but it's not a day style that'd be
good though break you some maybe as a
mod community I bet that exists I'm sure
does the men because they they have like
what fan main masks right yeah John wick
can be in that game and you know easy
there's a John wick theme
paid a thing I believe yeah if they say
she's gonna win DS right now to prove to
prove ever the big that's right the
Baconator is Wendy's who's saying it
isn't yeah I mean we we know we know
it's from Wendy's anymore
[Music]
h3h3 he's gonna be in pain a really
seriously Wow
cuz that's know don't put anyone you
make
you should wear on you should his model
should be him wearing those like and
that one that's one of my favorite I
think that'd be a good one
what was that one where he tried to be
in the boyband and he like painted his
face like completely orange oh that's a
good one too yeah like he's sick from Oh
acid apparently still has a game yeah so
let's display a spongebob game most of
our on the ps2 the only spongebob game
I've ever played was spongebob the movie
but I played on the PC and it's actually
a completely different game the console
versions were like a platforming games
yeah a little bit of peanut
Oh what you mean oh like battle for the
bikini bottom yeah I remember like
people actually enjoy playing that game
from what I know it's girlfriend likes
it it's like a pretty good game to
speedrun as far as I know like I'm
always afraid to stuff about it so I
think the movie game is like that on the
constants problem you see it's actually
a point click adventure game oh wow yeah
that actually like has some references
to like old LucasArts encierro games
it's a lot like the go amazing game but
it squandered 15 seconds worth of your
30 seconds
come on come on come on come on come on
that guy doesn't pass out good regularly
surprise
I like everyone's recommending weird Oh
No last one uh no you already got okay
there is some people here are
recommending like weird video games
where you can say chexquest
Wendy's mr. masks so Wendy's with their
mascot like Lara Croft and the
McDonald's game is payday okay so it's
you're playing Wendy but you're like
shooting like dinosaurs or Tigers that's
where they're kind of implying yeah a
little weird it's not very light on bran
with Wendy's I feel oh he says that
recon x89 says that people are hungry
will pop up on your radar
the minimo oh no I had I've noticed that
I have not been paying interested
mini-map at all the mini-map so I should
quite useful what I really is every time
you restart it puts you over there which
means I have to go all the way over here
and do this animation to do any the
sawmill which is Wendy's x-men Susie
doesn't woodshed yeah I would love to
see that okay look at this Chex quest
thing I've heard of checks class but
I've never played it
that's I go the muscle bound checks
piece Chex quest is a nonviolent yes
it's a Wolfenstein
part of my language but this is a pretty
great we have to find a way to play some
of these games at some point I'm into
that
sculpey King 88 says on Xbox one this
game sinking is actually for the Xbox
360 it was only some tells us it is not
backwards compatible
to my knowledge I didn't try actually
it's it was released on 6 for the 360
but it was you could play it on the Xbox
that's really what the same disc just
put it in let's see so yeah I imagine
they made it for the original Xbox and
then just put the packaging they just
made the packaging look like a 360
because like widescreen HD yeah right
Burger King leading the way with that
backwards compatibility yeah awesome
because I really didn't want to keep
nobody somehow sensing that's Harvick's
up to this the most important meal of
the day with a big smile the guys
reading it actually delicacies oh he is
yeah yeah we reasonable were interviewed
afterwards but it is unsure what they
said as their mouths were full
fast travel now cool what Williams
Grantham is asking for big bump in
unfortunately that's the only game out
of the three that we don't have with us
bike racers we could do a couple of call
the second ones maybe switch over to
that yeah oh whoa
this is pretty this is what I want I
like how it's a gated community and he's
just like standing right in the center
of it moving in there's a map Wow you
know what
something about the way this is like
structure the way there's all these
different people when they're moving
around it reminds me of like a hit man
level yeah where they all have their
paths that they take right things are
happening except instead of murdering
them you're just like giving them okay
you know what we need now right what we
need they need a hit man modd where this
level is in or or this model the seeking
model like as if a bald guy with a
barcode on the back of his head I wasn't
just business enough yeah that's exactly
was thinking I could balloon a pass out
oh so I have to wait until they're about
to pass out oh you see if I have to let
them slowly starve themselves and then
ripe for death I deliver the word dead
the food I'm saying ah kablooey says
this is the nuketown map before the bomb
hit yeah or that I was also thinking of
the also
[Music]
my rent ain't pretty much father
coincidence or Zen fault three now let's
follow fourth yeah this guy just scoping
out the new neighborhood you just moved
here because of his wife and children
golden retriever I start flashing right
yeah
[Music]
you wanna give it away another one over
on the twitch app ah yes
let's go with another play something
else cuz I'm really bored over watch
because because hang on I wish we could
play overwatch but unfortunately we have
to play sneaking yeah it's kind of the
rules by a livestream law alright so
next on the giveaways we're going to
giveaway on the twitch chat oh you
better hurry up no no I'm fine
painting that fence so if your porch
will be already gate fortunately we
already gave some stuff away for the
YouTube chat so we're gonna move over to
twitch so if you wanna head over there
you can still if you can get first time
you can still have a chance for some
Lego dimensions for giveaway that
garbage can
ah no oh she's dead
[Music]
swift wait was it trucks in swift
removals I wasn't there moving out okay
mailman just like that get the gun
disorder
I lost my chain though
[Music]
I guess passes how they have known
physics whatsoever they're just flat
Robbie Sousa what am i watching watching
sneak king the 2006 masterpiece the best
three dollars money can buy now five
dollars now five dollars
Nicholas in Phoenix says hello from
Indonesia well what's up Dan really far
indonesian that's rad why are you
watching this hungry I'm getting hungry
I'm not gonna lie
Spencer I was asking if it was free or
did they have the balls to charge money
for this they did have the balls to
charge money I think it came free though
if you bought like a certain meal I
think it was like discounted if you
bought it with
but now emailing hey that's a I mean if
they have that if they have the balls to
charge to stuff like what way they have
their like chicken fries those are just
weird okay I got two three minutes to
score a lot point
do you get more points for supermarkets
sorry
like remember I don't they I'm gonna
need an African Hey I'm logging in
Chipotle's er says only 11 years to
almost double in value this game makes
other investments look like crap
[Music]
that hole in the it's good good first
you
[Music]
this is no reply from Shiva
we'll make sure Shiva contacts yes as
well as well she has your handle so will
be will make sure that she gets see you
though we write that down to ourselves
just to make sure as well so for the
twitch chat with the people yeah was the
guy fixing his car alright so for twitch
chat if you would like to win pores are
remaining lego dimensions
figures you can answer this question
here that every and back in the
mid-2000s around the same time that
sneak king came out burger king had a
commercial for their tender crisp bacon
cheddar ranch sandwich and it starred
famous singer
you know this off the top of your head
yes Wow okay it's sort of famous singer
for a band I would the first person that
can name the band will win four of the
remaining Lego dimensions figures of
their choice oh we already got someone
already said it you already got it
Wow that looks very impressive chipotles
er it was in fact Hootie and the
Blowfish
congratulations Chipotle's here that was
quick
I'm very I've impressed and happy that
someone remembers that so Capote Lazer
if you would like to pick one of the
four remaining ones we have some
adventure time we have two Adventure
Time figures we have two fantastic
beasts one of which is a story pack
which is bigger we have a gremlins one
we have a Mission Impossible one
there's a there's a blind box one and
then one with I believe is mr. t let me
go grab that one I want you go grab that
stuff I'm gonna sneak are more people
here oh boy yeah so it's is mr. teets
via the 18 right there so if you want to
pick four of those you can pick any for
you would like
you can't get it done kid what we got
here
what am I doing here is insane oh you
guys giving up more things you know just
there's not much substance to this game
Joe alright once once we finish with
this is lost its luster pretty gritty
way are there any other places you can
go to AH some tiles have to do another
ten because it is 20 of her area oh my
god
well we go to downtown though Joey I
don't think I'm gonna feed all the bums
there how do you think do you think they
have that was her chicken fries oh boy
we're gonna get those way to the game
spot check
[Music]
what is this person doing
I didn't even do anything to them they
just died and they're just dead oh he's
he's peeping you see that wait look over
the fence
he's got the cold wait go a little bit
closer
he's got : right there he's looking
underneath someone over there what are
you waiting on bet you there's some
there's some yeah pervert I'm like
prairie dogs down there something
creeping on prairie dogs is that what
they call it nowadays
will you leave the people with their
memories yes I've never smoked a cousin
I watched it like last week it was a
joke in there about prairie dogs I wish
I could reference well look out
[Music]
Ryan says somehow they found the body
oh you can go in wow that's weird oh
it's a hiding spot yeah it's not
actually like but it's someone's house
actually stuff in there oh all it's a
it's a cul-de-sac you know middle
America they lock their doors
robot guys 64 now is that the Burger
King it is this is in fact the Burger
King
do they use him anymore in marketing I
don't I leave I believe they do
[Music]
all right I will get this last if
mission
fail or successor fail will switch to a
bucket bike racer alrighty how that is
okay yeah reconyx 89 seconds
we found the peeking tom even though
we're the ones that are you know quote
unquote free food easy death says you
have no sock giveaway there's no
slipping you slip it on socks don't
really like those socks
well sock I mean we technically you
still have the right like we didn't get
we're gonna give them away ball fine at
some point in their lives chance to give
away
[Music]
anybody hit the a button he do shrugs
wait good do about it
why is that carved like a real license
or means like like it's a California
that could be someone's actual license
plate it's like usually in games in
movies or whatever they just they have
like fake no like it'll say sneak King
on it yeah vanity plate but it's like
like a red chicken fries order number
four right is this our last one shirt
question the King doesn't get dizzy
he gets freaky the freak King likes you
freaking she was just about to go into
her house hey you wanna get freaky
here's a whopper have a whopper All
Right see ya oh I haven't seen bad sneak
tell you what the one where he was like
low to the ground
[Music]
contextual I was like Winnie when he's
near the walls or something do we find
out what uh whatever that one person
wanted to wanted to win they pass that
too late
[Music]
to Chipotle the chip Chipotle's are if
you're in the chat let me know which of
the four you'd like to win so I can I
can reserve them for you oh no I got an
answer we got gremlins Adventure Time
mister tuning fork us piece all right
[Music]
nope another person also going into that
house you know I don't think these
people like I think they're all just
walking into each other's houses Willie
your neighbors right yeah I think that's
like you do like a wall yeah you do a
house swap a house swap you just live in
each other's houses yeah it's like that
sure wife swap go with houses I bet
that's the thing that's probably the
show very hungry someone says it is a
hideo kojima made this game I would play
[Music]
Kadima like instead of cioppino guys
like those feed them a burger at the
same time or urges and then and then
they pass him it's the same gameplay but
there's a 30 minute long cut
cube says he's all about them socks
yeah gene Korea says this is creepy
stinking master is this the original
Xbox version nope 360 version there was
only one version it worked for both the
360 and the original Xbox oh okay then
alright so do we want to do we want to
switch over to pocket bike racer now
yeah let's see what that one's about
watch it into the full screen for a
second alright let me let me actually
grab the other glass prizes for the
giveaway okay thanks everyone for tuning
in to this live stream as you know we uh
we do these every weekday at 11 a.m.
me and Joey do Friday's next week next
Friday we're gonna be doing splatoon two
on launch day so make sure to tune in
for that we're gonna play the actual
relevant game for once for once and then
on Monday Jake and Mike are gonna be
playing some players unknown
battlegrounds yeah I knew they've been
they didn't playing into though a lot
like after work so make sense for them
to do a livestream of that they they got
a chicken dinner the other day actually
knows yesterday yeah they got a
yesterday yeah pretty good you know
someone says my voice doesn't match my
face I've always thought it Mellow hello
alright alright so we got in sneak King
has been retired and now we are moving
on to the one of the other games oh wow
again again I really like that they left
the background like the and so you just
still see the I haven't played this one
by the way that's good see there's some
charm
I like these openings are great no it's
like they're really pushing the
creepiness and they're not like afraid
to hide it I guess I bet this was a lot
of fun to make like these things yeah
the live-action parts
mmm and for the for the final giveaway I
don't know if we have anyone in the the
GameSpot site oh wow there's a critic
character oh yeah yeah so if you'd like
to win the the remaining four Lego
dimensions things figurines we have a
fantastic piece we have an adventure
time mission possible and then one blind
box right here head on over to our chat
on the game spot I'm gonna pick Joey oh
whatever for you I know if you saw these
other ones Brant biker I don't want to
say that guy's name Tiffany looks very
upset to be there and jolly I think Joey
here please I'm gonna see if I can
recreate you okay that's fair I don't
know if the face is gonna be any
different no okay am I actually cheap I
can't tell if things are actually
changing here oh it is it just takes
forever okay my top color well I'm
wearing a purple jacket right now let's
go to purple okay close enough
maybe yeah Brett okay black black pants
okay probably these skin tone like more
I'm not that dark now that last one
there he's looking kind of sick leave
yeah that's not man that's way too pale
maybe the first one that's fine yeah I
say that's the best clothes all right
this is there I am the perfect
recreation of Joey I mean Joey Joey I
don't want to change it
well right it's oh you owe a why yeah
yes yes I
I'm a terrible speller you think I you
think that'd be an easy one
Joey would you like to create another
now that says it's uncanny uncanny it's
very uncanny have you ever played making
Mouse Speedway I know I played a Mickey
Mouse racing game on my gameboy color I
forget what's called rare yeah that was
the Speedway the movie was at Speedway
then they would for the n64 and then
like a port for the the Game Boy Color I
played so yes if that does that name of
that game then I I did play that why I
keeps you on it okay it makes you do all
that again alright just go to the
single-player I think anyone's playing
online no I think that's a local
multiplayer xbox live player let's do
free play here it's good instruction the
fancier yes I think we have to go there
all right then we'll do the King's
garden what's CC are we going down okay
forgot the King Brooke Burke subservient
Chicken whopper jr. Winston oh man I
love going to the BIR King and sing how
to Winston biker
very are Joey holes big Joey no Little
Dipper look at that top speed like
there's no reason why you wouldn't pick
that right yeah let's go at Alan I'm
sure it'll be fine we'll be perfect all
right we got we have a couple people a
couple is it literally a couple people
in the game spa chat three so if you
haven't already wool again even the way
the rest of why buttons for taunting
that's very important the rest of our
Lego dimensions will be giving those
away or press the left button what the
left button what do you maybe just on
the d-pad the let the left button that
could mean so many things
left button what press it to wait taunt
them again
I don't know yeah why wouldn't you just
press Y press Wyatt off taunt them but
then press the left button Joey grand
thief says play online I don't believe
anyone is actually playing this game
surprisingly enough probably not skybox
a skybox looks bad
that's it looks a little truman show ish
oh my
well you got whopper jr. okay I don't
even know what accelerate is okay it's
direct can I dress yes why should it
told Taylor it's a blemish against 60
frames per second because this looks
pretty smooth yeah this is some you know
perfect even knows the quality that 60
frames a second this is very important
if it all racing game alright cool
whopper jr. at least oh the drifting is
bad drifting is bad Joey
I honestly there's just not drift I
think I could just not drift because the
turning is actually like doing pretty
good on its own like I kind of don't
need it okay so I think you get oh you
got a rock it can you use your items yes
yeah screw you know like it stick a
diamond I think that was what that was
view oh oh I think what it is is you
bill but meter
and then you can pick which one you want
team hands so it's like I want to save
up my meter to use the better thing I
see a rot or like a firework a dynamite
stick a rock
golden the yellow brick road from Wizard
of Oz and then no this is actually from
that commercial I was talking about
really yeah oh wow that's actually we're
like it's it's if not exactly whoa Oh
hit by something I got hit by a flash
bang also it inverted my controls for a
second down the way the drifting curling
bit
before we Hernandez is a poor-man's
Mario Kart I don't it's not just the
poor man point all right it's like the
homeless man's Mario it's like the poor
man's I don't know what's another bad
like new space race yeah like a poorer
version of an already bad I don't even
know what happened there you know I
really really wanna figure what this
Left button is I think you've got the I
catch a scam wha oh no Joe is fat you
got the longest wheelie though hell yeah
silver rocket left this drifting is not
good but do you think of something you
can get used to maybe it's not like oh
it's it just takes some time the links
oh no oh that was nice yeah
maybe it wasn't last got four points for
that he wants to know where you get your
outfit Joey weren't this outfit this is
this was given to us by someone and like
someone visited the office and gave
because I don't know where it came from
oh I want to pick a different a person
you don't want to use me anymore
try whopper jr. everything's good
I'll stick with the same car here don't
forget that you can steer when you're in
the air all right Wow oh yeah it's funny
because I've been getting some pretty
good mileage out of this like I used it
for end up so the lobby
nose nose on there yeah I remember that
I did not get at pimps are us hence our
house did he debt the same man these
loading times are longer than they
should be
grand theft says this is a BK promoter
the brand I would never go back to DK
again I don't know I I am weirdly hungry
I don't know if I'm gonna say I want her
for Burger King but I am just hungry in
general I'm just hungry
it is 12 o'clock oh where is this is the
the king's castle his cow is pretty big
all that Burger King money you know
man this is just like the king you know
minimum wage he gets all the money
everyone knows have to race around won't
know if he's actually competing he's in
first place right now yeah they're
actually all competing for a livable
wage even the chicken I like how he
especially the chicken the the whopper
jr. cart like how his is a the angle
King Joey so bad you ain't go his
buddies like fold it over the buns
pulled it over I think I'm getting it's
go something like let go and there's a
break as well what what's very this Oreo
cookie I cannot ask you gonna joke about
that look at this yeah where's it little
sparks coming out yeah I gotta get my
level three booze
yeah she's the chick installed even the
AI seems to be having trouble to tell
you know you're being good holds a
shield yeah it's like the lowest level
there's a llama they serve lamb is a
d-cup
- do they serve peacock lamb is not
mama is like we will te comminity
that is a very skin-tight outfit
there you go Winston is on the last lap
isn't that say that person who's Bert BK
look Bert oh it's just a model
wait what looks just like a model on the
skin yeah he was on Dancing with the
Stars was she when your girl I got your
verdict controls or price controls got
the first shilling in a Burger King
commercial she might have been I'm part
of that deal was like hey you also get
to be in this match Mario Kart ripoff
whom she was again well there you go
oh hi kids pretty good holding on it
recon hexina also says Burger King did
just advertised through the games also
three TV shows like Arrested Development
and American Dad like I think the arrest
of the Velma scene where they go to the
birthing is one of my favorites that's
Rico where they just Tobias is just like
it's a wonderful restaurant you can get
a refill any drink here will be free
I do like commercials which is very
blatant about their you know I always
think of the Wayne's World
yeah alright we are going to watch it
give away that last one I'll try these
other so we're gonna give away the last
four of these and unfortunately you
won't have a choice but these are so
pretty good thing we got lego dimensions
in chicken here blind box fantastic peas
Adventure Time and Mission Impossible
hold on let me look up something real
quick okay
just make sure I got my trivia correct
all right so if you are in the GameSpot
chat right now and would like to win the
remaining four of these Lego dimension
figures answer me this question in the
90s
Burger King had a head of kids they
advertised towards kids with their their
kids club characters which included lots
of very multicultural multi cultural
assortment of no kids in various
different outfits and one of them was in
a wheelchair and I want you to name that
one that was in the wheelchair it was
also a McDonald's had a similar thing to
right no they just had the the really
creepy
like this like I think called Mac and me
though Oh dad some movie yeah the alien
maybe universe like a kid in a
wheelchair I feel like yeah that was in
the wheelchair oh it looks like we got a
winner
who won well the answer we got food oh
good one and it was wheels was the kid
with you - of course
where does he know what this
so congratulations you got the remaining
four Lego dimensions figures make sure
to hit up I lost that was a quick one
wow that was a that's a short course Eva
I'm sure you know her twitter handle
already she'll get you these a wonderful
figures for you alright we're gonna do
the final course here with the king
himself are you going with king yeah we
can fire oh those are bottle rockets Oh
gran thief just checked and he said
these games actually helped increase
profits for Burger King no and he
couldn't couldn't cost that much money
to make them right oh yeah I don't know
Bob Jones says these weren't a thing in
the 90s no this was uh this isn't the
90s oh this was or well know that
commercial yeah the the Burger King kids
club okay hmm yeah I guess these was
like an early two-thousands thing more
wasn't it I don't really know like the
four wheels his description is a
Caucasian paraplegic boy in a wheelchair
with brown hair blue eyes and freckles
weird that that's their description not
his personality but he's defining like
his features he's got his eye color I
kind of like all the other like this is
better looking like
this no no like but yeah but this
suburban area looks better than the
suburban area and sneaking like visually
fine much I would say the the lighting
was a little bit but grass texture like
yeah so you're gonna be tough yeah the
kings uh whatever reason harder to
control you guys came okay yeah I don't
think it's mostly difference between
care is thinking about the part booking
it though Oh in the pool so there's uh
when you do the jump they go which is
like kind of a Mario like but like not
really it's weird
there you go jump
I got flashbangs why are all my things
come on come on come on
hot jens's I'm terrible at this no
that's not the week yeah I know I'm
distracted by the you don't have
headphones on joy but the that laughs
there is to it later Oh weird it's
upsetting I'll just look at the other
characters in that in I always had these
like very obviously nicknames like a guy
who was a
I don't need this I think it's part of
the soundtrack I think it's when they
jump the screening it's very weird
try and get I'm trying to get the group
here
no sorry smells loud I apologize
I shouldn't know you guys not the game
to it to blow up a mic on get the
high-powered weapon right hmm oh I do
that's the one that reverses there I
don't think that's worth it oh it's ages
it's pretty bad at least for me it's
pretty bad
that's for Java hard for that only only
affects one person with the Truitt's and
all other ones you can keep getting more
cars and more rockets
was it last few where we call it we call
it any we're gonna call it here that is
a pocket bike racers and sneaking two
variables wonderful game yeah first time
playing them pocket white race is
terrible I wouldn't ever recommend
playing that sneaking's not bad it's
just very repetitive yeah I don't think
we can give recommendations to either
now sound like that serious basis but
not at all there are fun distractions if
anything else I think we're good yeah I
think we're good thanks for tuning in
like I said we do these streams every
weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific time me
enjoying next Friday are gonna be doing
splatoon - yeah which is very exciting
wait definitely looking forward to that
one and then on Monday Jake and Mike are
gonna be doing players unknown
battlegrounds which should be pretty
good thanks for tuning in guys and see
you next week
[Music]